[Music]
we at the future of life institute asked
what the world might look like between
now and 2045 if we build advanced
artificial intelligence
and steer away from disaster
towards the future we actually want
we had an amazing response to the
competition with 144 submissions from 44
countries and we loved reading about
these worlds and we're really impressed
by the effort and the quality
to enter the competition participants
were asked to submit four components
a timeline of events from today to 2045
two short stories
answers to a series of prompts about
their world and a media piece to give
flavor
to their world
and all of these components had to tie
together in a coherent fashion and we
were looking for worlds that were both
plausible and aspirational and this was
really hard
there were a ton of great entries and
the judges were very diverse in their
backgrounds and opinions
even when they could agree on what was
technically plausible or implausible
which wasn't always
they often disagreed about just what was
their favorite what world would they
want to inhabit
what story was most compelling to them
etc and so this is part of the reason we
wanted to bring more voices in and have
more feedback we want to have as many
people included in the discussion as we
possibly can
um there were a few worlds that were so
aspirational like i mean i was overjoyed
after reading them
but i couldn't really quite point how to
get from here to there
and then you know vice versa there were
a few that were like scarily realistic
you know it was really hard to see how
that is actually like a future that one
wants to inhabit something challenge
obviously to strike a balance between
these different tradeoffs
after much deliberation the judges have
finalized their choices
on behalf of the future of life
institute i present to you the winners
of the 2022 world building contest
i have a sort of background in writing
uh rational fiction
which is where
you sort of take these bizarre
world-building premises and then you
find a way that that could make sense
and i don't know why that's so
interesting but it was a lot of fun for
us this was really a great project so
this is a really nice excuse to sit and
have these discussions together and the
complexity comes from so many different
minds and debates and arguments that we
had a lot of fun to kind of bring
together a bunch of ideas that we had
about like what
seems most exciting about the future and
then kind of pull those together under
you know into a coherent ish scenario
making a particular path really vivid
is
probably necessary to
enable people to believe in it there's a
shocking dearth of any kind of
optimistic
sci-fi
uh in um on the small live screens oh my
god super hard to think about
aspirational futures we just like it was
really difficult like what is what is
the aspiration
now that the contest is over we're
working on showcasing these worlds and
connecting them with storytellers
just recently the world builds were on
display at an event in los angeles put
on by hollywood health and society where
they announced their screenwriting
contest so that's something that our
organization tries to do is how to
connect technologists with people who
want to tell stories and so
we realized that like navigating
technology as a plot device can be kind
of overwhelming and i guess the hope is
that more visions of positive futures
and popular media can inspire and help
us achieve them
there's not a lot of that sort of
conversation going on
in society and nfl i wanted to help
jumpstart it
how do we get more positive visions of
the world how do we get conversation
going about what sorts of worlds we
would actually want to live in
through media through discussions
through
public debate
how can we start that process so that we
can as a society have a little bit more
of a positive goal rather than just
avoiding the negative